thank you thank you okay 30 minutes to
lunch we can do this together okay so my
talk is called got SSL as you guys know
more people are connected to the web
today than ever before and for more
places so you know we're connected with
our laptops and our phones our tablets
probably soon enough with with personal
devices and accessories and we access
the internet from untrusted and and
sometimes even hostile networks you know
with so much of our lives moving online
it's imperative we're taking steps to to
protect our data in our users data so so
this talk is my call to arms to all of
you as developers and in the next 30
minutes I hope to convince you about the
necessity and practicality of SSL and
then give you some pointers to show you
how to how to actually make that happen
so this is probably a good place to
start
what's SSL it stands for Secure Sockets
Layer and it's a cryptographic protocol
designed to provide communication
security over the Internet I imagine a
lot of people have heard of it
I'll just still do a quick intro it
guarantees privacy and it does this via
encryption and integrity so this
prevents somebody from snooping or
tampering with the internet connection
it's it's had its share of security
flaws over the years but it's the
leading and primary way today and really
the only way to ensure any kind of data
communication security on the Internet
there's a couple of acronyms that are
thrown around interchangeably so so very
quickly I'll clarify these TLS if you've
heard of it is for most intents and
purposes the same as SSL you can you can
consider them synonyms if we want to be
precise
SSL 3.1 was renamed to tls/ssl was the
original name of the specification when
this came out in the mid 90s from
Netscape and TLS is the IETF standard
name but they're interchangeable I will
refer to this as the protocol as SSL
throughout this talk and then HTTPS is
HTTP
over SSL and I imagine most people are
familiar with this too it's actually not
a protocol but it's really just the
layering of the security capabilities of
SSL and standard HTTP so if you're into
internet protocol stacks this is how it
looks I'll leave it as an exercise for
all of you guys to read about the
specifics of the SSL protocol but you
should know that it consists of two
phases so there's this first initial
phase between the client often case your
browser and the web server and this is
based on public private key cryptography
this initial part of the protocol is a
handshake which is used to create a
shared key a shared secret and the
shared secret is used by the second part
of the SSL protocol to actually encrypt
the communication of a session so
networking on the Internet it feels safe
right we open up a browser we send a
request to load some page in sort of the
comfort of our of our device the
response page is delivered back to us
and it feels like it's immediate it's
fast it feels like we're talking
directly to the website but in reality
we know that it's not like this this
direct connection and if you serve data
over plain HTTP between your browser and
the server you have absolutely no
guarantees that the data that's been
sent from your client to the server has
not been tampered with or suit with some
by some person that has access to the
network along the way so I'm sure people
are familiar with the comic xkcd it's
really hard for me to do a presentation
without including some comic because
there's always something relevant
I'll give people a second to to note our
woman in the middle on the open Wi-Fi
network she's performing a
man-in-the-middle attack and as the name
of the tech suggests this is when an
attacker places himself or herself or
their malicious software in between a
victim and a valuable resource and
and today's talk I'm gonna say that's
your website so there are always always
almost always a few places someone can
access the network between requests
coming from a browser and the actual web
server so for example who's on Google
guest right now I imagine there's a
couple people ok lots of people so this
is going through the Wi-Fi router that's
run by Google I don't know who it's run
by maybe you do and maybe you trust them
but then it's going on to some ISP and
and potentially other intermediate
proxies between you know you on your
laptop or your phone and that site and
then you know through all those hops on
the way back and if you are using HTTP
this is an entirely clear text protocol
again you have no guarantee that this
data has not been logged or tampered
with that's gonna be the meme kind of
you know through this talk do you know
or trust the people that run each one of
those hops if not you should be
concerned so even more depressingly even
if you want HTTPS you can actually still
run into some issues if the site doesn't
avoid some common downgrade vectors from
from HTTP to HTTPS very rarely type in
the full URL the scheme you know HTTP
and the URL where they want to go when
they want to visit some site so these
things end up automatically either being
redirected by the site or you're
clicking some Lincoln and going there
and all of these are opportunities for
downgrade attacks I'm going to talk at
the end about how to actually avoid
those but the Internet is a scary place
I'm gonna go over just two tools that
make these types of man-in-the-middle
attacks really easy I encourage you to
check them out maybe someone is running
them in the audience right now but the
first one is called SSL strip so men in
the middle attacks have been known about
for a really long time
this tool came out in 2009 just as kind
of a proof of concept of how easy these
are to actually mount but what SSL strip
does is it exploits the fact that
often sites are still sending some
requests over HTTP as I mentioned most
people don't type it directly into the
browser they're either clicking a link
or actually getting redirected from a
site so there's this this window of
opportunity for somebody to
man-in-the-middle and actually replace
outbound links that are intended to be
HTTPS with HTTP and back and also it
does some homograph style URL
replacement and it even throws in a lock
icon so people that are looking for that
as a sense of security you know get that
warm fuzzy feeling but unfortunately
without the security as the south strip
came out in 2009 one that got quite a
lot of broad attention was called
Firesheep this one came out following
year in 2010 and it was much more usable
from an attacker standpoint you had a
nice a nice user interface so that's
probably why I got a little bit more
attention Firesheep was a passive
man-in-the-middle attack and then it
just listened to an open Wi-Fi network
for cookies that were being sent in the
clear authentication cookies and then it
would pop up people's accounts that it
was able to hijack and you could just
click on them and and automatically
listen in on you know someone's chat or
login to their Facebook account so a
site without SSL is telling its users
that they don't care about the privacy
and integrity their privacy and
integrity so in the 90s HTTPS was mainly
considered I think something that the
banking industry had to consider but
it's just not about banking anymore and
serving over plain HTTP is totally
insecure leave with that message
neither the browser nor the server can
trust any of the data that's sent
between over HTTP and this is a sad
state for users and and site operators
as well and we know it's not just a
plausible risk so we have evidence of
both targeted and large-scale
government-run snooping operations and
awkward laugh
you know if you care about the privacy
and integrity of your users data you
need to be using SSL I would even go so
far as to say if you don't care about
the privacy and integrity of your users
data what kind of app are you actually
how interesting is the app that you're
writing there are very few exceptions
that that I can think of where this
should not be seen as a requirement okay
so hopefully you guys all want SSL now
so it's time to get it and I will
continue my sales pitch by saying that
SSL is fast cheap and and easier than
ever to get which is good news so on my
slide I have a quote from Adam Langley
who works at Google and it's done a
tremendous amount of work getting SSL
support at Google and kind of across
across the internet and one of the most
common excuses that I hear from
developers about why they don't have SSL
is the performance and cost impact and
to be fair ten years ago this was a
legitimate concerning complaint I
mentioned this first part of the SSL
protocol you do public key cryptography
and this is expensive computationally
it's really just all the cost is in this
handshake
after that it's it's never really been
too much of an issue ten years ago this
required dedicated hardware it's not the
case today
this quote was from from 2010 when
Google started supporting SSL for Gmail
by default for all users and it required
no additional hardware and really had a
very limited performance impact so it's
not too expensive running an application
over SSL is really no different from
communicating directly on TCP so there's
very few application modifications you
need to do as far as performance goes
you'll want to check out operational
things operational pieces to actually
SSL deployment like how and where you
deploy your SSL servers and and record
size and memory buffers and
lot of little configuration things which
I'm not going to go over today but which
there's a really good reference for in
this book that I have links they're sort
of links sprinkled throughout the slides
if anything is interesting this book
high-performance browser networking is
by ilya who i think spoke either earlier
yesterday or speaking today and it has a
great checklist of things that you'll
want to consider when deploying ssl and
it's free so again no excuse SSL is is
not a performance hindrance it's also
free so you can get free certs from s
from start SSL com this is just one that
I've used and I know other people use
you can get free for non-commercial uses
if you have a commercial use it's
something like sixty dollars so it's
cheap and you know we have it it's it's
fast it's cheap and I'm even gonna go as
so far as to say that SSL is is easy to
deploy it's deceptively easy to deploy
in fact so there's a couple mistakes the
people need to avoid but there's a
really useful guide that's put out by
SSL labs comm and it goes over all of
the things that you need to do in detail
and more importantly has an automated
tester so you can actually check that
you did everything right and and fix all
the mistakes and and then feel confident
that you're you're getting all these
things right so SSL is it's it's fast
it's cheap it's easy get it and then
let's get it right so you can test for
your actual SSL deployment using SSL
labs comm but I want to go over a couple
of the application bugs that I see most
commonly so all sites fall into three
categories when it comes to SSL adoption
there are the sites which don't offer it
at all for HTTP only sites users should
expect absolutely no security at least
they know what they're getting
then there's sites that only serve
exclusively over HTTPS or a non SSL and
in this case users should expect you
know private and untempered
communication for the most part barring
barring any any bugs we don't know about
in the world is a happy place and then
there are the sites that intentionally
or sometimes even inadvertently are
serving both over HTTP and HTTPS site
HTTPS we call this mixed content or
sites with mixed content and this is
where we run into some some problems
so unfortunately situations where you're
serving some of your site or some
resources that you're fetching over HTTP
can lead to downgrade attacks if you can
avoid the situation you should do it if
not and this is this is the case for a
lot of sites you're going to need to
take some extra considerations into
account so as I said if you're serving
anything over HTTP you need to take some
extra steps to avoid some
man-in-the-middle attacks these are
specific classes of man-in-the-middle
attacks so I talked about downgrade
attacks you can also leak cookies if
anybody can tamper the data that can
inject script and actually do like a
cross-site scripting attack and render
script which kind of you know use
whatever security what you would have
gone with SSL even if you don't care
about security you need to care about
mixed content bugs because browsers are
going to make the experience for your
users worse so as of chrome 29 chrome
blocks mixed content that is coming from
an iframe javascript cascading style
sheets and plug-in loads by default
Firefox has similar behavior and you can
see in the the top bar that's what the
chrome bar looks like if a user tries to
visit your site over SSL but you have
any kind of active content being served
over HTTP it's not going to load by
default and they're gonna actually have
to click to load so your page is
probably gonna break you're just gonna
be annoyed because I have to press a
button just to get the page to work and
and that's X also browsers block other
types of content like images or they
don't
block them but you automatically lose
your your green icon so you you lose
that warm fuzzy kind of assurance to
users that you care about security
because you're serving some mixed
content you also get a little warning in
chrome that you can you can click on so
as I said even if you don't care about
mixed content for security sake you
should care about it because users are
going to get integrated experience when
they visit your sites at least in Chrome
and Firefox so how do we actually fix
mixed content bugs thankfully it's it's
it's fairly easy but we need to do is
make sure that all of our resources are
loaded by HTTPS that are loaded on an
HTTPS page by HTTPS so if these
resources are on the same domain you can
just use relative URLs if you have to
use an absolute path you want to omit
the scheme or the protocol and the
browser will figure it out by itself in
the second example I actually include an
example of a scheme relative URL which
can look kind of funky if you've never
seen it before but it works so that's
how you fix mixed content bugs not too
hard
mixed content is a big one maybe
arguably the one that's a little bit
harder to fix because there may be
multiple instances of this but another
really common application bug that I've
seen is not preventing sensitive cookies
from leaking over HTTP so if your
cookies are sensitive and in a lot of
cases they are there they're doing
something with authentication or save
preferences it's imperative that you
ensure they don't get sent over an HTTP
connection and to do this you have to
ensure that you have the secure bit set
on your set cookie header it's
unfortunate that it requires that
because a lot of apps have have missed
that and this is actually how Firesheep
worked right it relied on the fact that
a lot of sites were not setting
sensitive cookies with a secure bit and
they're easy to too stiff and then
used to hijack people's accounts so a
recent an interesting development in the
the wild world of SSL is something
called strict Transport Security this is
a mechanism that allows websites to opt
in for HTTPS only rendering and also
strict HTTPS certain validation so the
first tool I mentioned called SSL strip
it exploited the fact that most people
don't type in HTTPS when they when they
visit a site they're typing in just the
domain name or clicking on a link or
going to some bookmark and in that case
there's a small window of opportunity
where the user makes HTTP requests that
someone's allowed to man in the middle
so strict Transport Security or HSTs is
it's abbreviated attempts to address
that that threat once this header is
saved in the browser it's gonna bump
automatically all HTTP traffic to HTTPS
and it will reject you know any attempt
to visit that site over over an
unencrypted channel so this is actually
really good I'm seeing more sites adopt
this there's still a very small window
of opportunity that an attacker can and
in the middle where someone's just
installed the browser and they actually
don't have this this header set yet by
the applicant by the application so
chrome actually Chrome and Firefox
actually come with some hard-coded sites
that want to that have elected into
always using HSTs so some examples are
twitter paypal there's google sites on
there and LastPass if you as a developer
want your site to only be ever accessed
over SSL you can actually just file a
bug file if you you visit the link on
this slide you'll you'll get all the
right contacts and we can include your
your site as well in this hard-coded
list but that's strict Transport
Security another cool and even more
recent development is something called
public key pinning
so public key pinning is designed to
give website operators a means to
restrict which certificate authorities
can actually issue certificates for
their sites so this feature has been
deployed in for Google Chrome for a
while and it has proven to be useful in
preventing attacks and actually making
the public aware of them so if people
potentially heard about in the news
there was a dutch CA that was exploited
in issuing forged certificates for
google.com it was believed that the
hackers were targeting Iranian citizens
start pinning is the feature that
actually allowed us to detect these
forged certs so there are two proposals
being worked on right now to try to make
this standard and we're hoping that that
happens and that other websites can
actually use the public key pinning
feature at some point okay
so I've spent my entire time talking up
here about how awesome SSL is but I do
want to make sure people leave with a
totally accurate impression of what this
gives you because SSL is not a security
Silver Bullet it's good you need to do
it it's it's not security magic dust and
the only thing you have to do so go over
a couple disclaimers so first as a cell
it doesn't actually guarantee 100%
privacy
so we're piggybacking HTTP entirely on
top of SSL so we know that all of that
is encrypted we get you know the request
URL query parameters constants of the
page headers and cookies all that's
encrypted in private so so this is good
but you know SSL it's it's working on
top of the TCP layer so which requires
IP address and port numbers so these are
necessarily going to be leaking to
somebody who's listening on on an open
network and also all you can't infer the
actual contents of the communication you
can still infer the end
and duration of the communication so
you're potentially left open to some
kind of traffic analysis or pattern
analysis attacks and in very specific
services it's been demonstrated that you
could infer something useful from this
and people have countered this with
padding attacks but the reality is this
is just not something that the vast
majority of applications are going to
need to worry about but you know you
should know that there are some
information side side channels that are
being leaked so also as I said SSL is a
transport protocol so attacks at other
layers are not going to be prevented
so in particular IP level threats of
denial of service attacks or any kind of
network spoofing attacks they're not
protected by SSL and then also you have
to consider other web application
vulnerabilities if your front of
cross-site scripting or SQL injection
these things aren't you know prevented
by SSL so you still got to think about
that but that's said SSL is it's the
best thing we have today as far as
protecting users communication data
communication and ensuring any kind of
level of security for your site and your
users so earlier this week couple days
ago the e FF published this article with
associated infographic about SSL
adoption from the list of companies in
there who's got your back program so the
program are companies that have you know
committed to preventing unlawful
government access to their data I think
it's interesting go Google go Twitter go
Dropbox and you know some other ones
that are getting five stars across the
board for what they're doing but I think
this is interesting for people as a user
you should check this out and you should
be demanding as a cell for the services
you use so you know file bugs chime in
on forums and and grab your digital
pitchforks demand SSL for what you use
and provide it for your users - this is
another cool project
it's called SSL pulse and this project
aims to measure the effective security
of SSL across the internet so they look
at about 200,000 SSL enabled websites
from Alexis you know list of most
popular sites they refresh their data
every month and this is just - two
graphs encourage you to check out the
project cuz they show a lot of other
statistics about where we're at SSL wise
and they've chemists kept the same
methodology and sample approach for the
past two years so you can kind of see
trends an SSL a year ago today well your
November 2012 we had about just under
15% SSL adoption so it's really cool to
see that we've we're now almost 50
percent adoption at least in these top
sites but you know need your help - to
help push that even further and yeah
that's it I think um I hope you're
you're not just hungry for lunch but
hungry to get SSL working I I promise
you that if you you know if you're not
enjoying enjoying the summit or need
something to do this evening you can get
SSL set up on a personal site for free
started SSL calm in less than an hour
and that's like why you're chatting to
your friends and like eating a bag of
chips
test it out get it working get us so